皆さんこんにちはこんばんはこちら stick up んです
今日はねー
言葉の勉強についての色々なアドバイスや橋
発表があるんです
俺はですねー
ここ今週の土曜日日本時間の
今週の土曜日朝10時
グーグルプラスで
インターネット会議があります
それはグーをパスの払うという技術を使いまして
私も含めて10人が画面でフェイストゥフェイスで買おうと顔を合わせて話ができます
今度それを日本語でやりたいまあ将来はまた英語でもやると思うんですけれども
今回は日本語でと
であの
今回ですねそのリンクのいわゆる
2ポイントを人たち新しい梅林のいろんな説明をですね特にレッスンヴェイド
今説明もしたいし皆さん
凛子使っていらっしゃる方あるいは
使ってみてけどに行ったけどやめましたとか使おうと
一同を使いたいとかそういう人たちとあのやはりあってですね
意見交換をしたいんです
でその会議に参加するために
グーグルプラスのリンクページに
いらしてその電気ですね ur オーダー
このビデオの下のいわゆる説明の牧師に入れておりますけれどもそこへいらしてですね
そしてまあバス1を出したりあるいは私であるリンクの提供をソロスルー
しょうゆ風な形ですね
我々にあのやはり connect すれば今度
必ず今度土曜日の10時の会議にあの招待しますから
でがたちとしてはですねこの会議は
あの参加する人の数が10人いわゆる
画面に出てくる人が数は10人だけでも他の人がそれを見てまたいろんなコメントか
質問を出すこともできます私はそれを見てまたできるだけ
お答えします処理と同時にそれが youtube 私のそのちゃのうですねちゃ寝ろ
フォローしている人たちにはですね宝幢寺褒章されます
そして最終的にはこれが youtube のビデオにもなります
そういうような会議なんですよだか
から是非リンクに興味のある方あるいは今使ってる人
方たちとかなんか指示もがあった人たち方たちとかぜひいらしてください
私は楽しみにしてますそれじゃあ土曜日10:00お会いしましょう
それは土曜日の10時の日本時間ですよねそれは他の
a
場所ではまた時間とかいい一日も海が変わると思うんですよ
日本時間の朝の10時それじゃ
たに楽しみにさようなら